what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with spider-verse but this one
is going to be a little bit different
and kind of exotic and the reason why i
call it that will become clear here in a
little bit but what this does is it
actually picks up with the death of the
original spider if you want to call it
that it's technically sp
dr the funny thing about this is this is
supposed to be inspired by neon genesis
and we'll talk about that here in a
minute but it seems like it's more
inspired by like pacific rim or maybe
pacific rim is more inspired by it i
don't really know the important thing
here is that the previous pilot of the
spider suit is basically killed and they
say that like spider is still intact and
so what this does is it actually follows
up with the daughter of this guy a girl
by the name of penny so we can largely
assume that maybe it's peter parker
we're not really given a definitive
answer in fact these two individuals say
that it's like her aunt mae and her
uncle ben but they're really more akin
to scientists but this is also kind of
dark too right because this girl's in
this room and she almost kind of seems
detached right they're like you know are
you aware of what happened and she's
like yes my father was part of spider
and my father died and that's basically
it so it's like damn it almost has a
kind of futuristic sort of young kids
who are basically adults because of like
what their life is like at that point in
time again we're not given a whole lot
of information here but basically what
they tell her is that the spider is
actually in the room with her and that
in effect she seems to be the only
person who's genetically compatible with
the actual suit and so by releasing the
spider into the room basically it will
bond with her and they even go as far as
to say like it's unpleasant right like
it's already been released into the room
he will have found you by now and if it
chooses to bond with you if you're
genetically compatible you will survive
the experience and that's exactly what
happens right like the spider bites with
her and then basically bonds with her
now this seems to be the kind of neon
genesis element coming into play but
again there's no indication here that
the suit is modeled after like adam or
lilith or anybody akin to that whole
concept instead what it really looks
like is the suit itself is one half of
the equation it's a yin and yang kind of
thing so basically the spider is in and
of itself or at least seems to be part
technological and so when the spider
bonds itself to a host that allows the
host to control the spider suit so it's
kind of cool that's why i say that
element seems to be more on par with
like pacific rim where you had like
drifting and that kind of a thing that
that sort of situation where two people
working together would basically pilot
the suit except in this instance it's
the host and the spider that control the
suit because of the fact that this is
very much a futuristic city even though
we're not given a whole lot of context
here you end up basically finding out
that five years after this this
reality's version of mysterio launches
an attack now unlike mysterio that we're
familiar with where he's basically a guy
with an orb for a head and you know
looks kind of crazy but also cool at the
same time and does some wild stuff this
version of mysterio is basically
contained in a giant orb the other part
of this is the guy's kind of being a
dick he's quite literally flying around
the city just spraying people with a
hallucinogenic substance i mean that's
kind of a jerk thing to do just like
flying around and just like spraying
people with what's basically a fire
extinguisher filled with hallucinogenic
gas it's just mean man it's just mean
it's really all that is
[Laughter]
but the whole time he's kind of talking
about that he basically says things like
your lives are boring right my art is
panic your laws my rules that kind of a
thing so the overall gist here seems to
be that he's pretty basic right there
really doesn't seem to be a whole lot
here he's not part of some rebel force
that's trying to overthrow the existing
government or anything like that but the
other thing about this is that you end
up having penny who basically arrives on
the scene now having done this for about
five years she seems to really have a
good grasp on how to control the suit
not only that this has all the basic
spider elements that you would expect to
see right the ability to shoot webbing
essentially out of its arms being able
to like crawl up and down walls and so
on and so forth but also breaking into
this orb which is controlled by mysterio
who actually does have an orb on his
head it's one of these things where like
immediately penny makes her assault but
when that happens and essentially the
gas is blown directly at her she's
warned that because she's in such a
close proximity and that while there are
filtration units on the suit itself in
the end it's a very very just strong
version of this substance of this gas
and so she will ultimately succumb to it
which she actually does she literally
kind of starts going crazy in terms of
seeing like all these you know wild
images and so on and so forth about what
you would imagine when like a 14 year
old girl is blasted with a
hallucinogenic gas right kind of what
you would expect her imagination running
wild now the other part of this and one
of the things that we're shown here is
it's not just penny by yourself and this
i thought was really really cool that
it's basically a kind of hive mind
system which is to say she essentially
gets feedback from people from her
actual base of operations her uncle ben
and aunt may and they can see what's
going on through the suit now whether or
not this is a result of the fact that
penny is so young and so because of that
she kind of needs a bit of guidance or
because this is just how the system
functions and her father was part of
this exact same system we're not really
told i'm inclined to believe it's the
latter right that it's just kind of the
the entire system in terms of how it
works but she's actually informed by her
aunt may and uncle ben that because of
the fact that she as a biological being
will succumb to the gas and will begin
to hallucinate the gas actually doesn't
affect spider or the suit and so because
of that she can basically just kind of
close her eyes and allow the psychic
link to work so this is kind of one part
of that element of yes penny's in
control of everything but the suit and
spider are as much a part of her as her
brain and her heart and her organs and
all that kind of stuff and so she does
exactly that she actually closes off her
eyes and basically forms or at least
builds into that psychic link with
spider which in turn controls the suit
and that allows the entire conflict to
unfold with her ultimately coming out on
top now of course we end up finding out
that basically mysterio's like a crazy
fan and kind of a wild thing here he
looks like quentin choir from the x-men
right like kid omega the omega level
telepath obviously it's not him but it
kind of looks like it and that seems to
be the thing here right he's like you
know i hate my voice you don't know me
like i'm just a fan but i could have
been anything to you and so we don't
know if that's really him just kind of
you know going on some babbling tirade
because he's crazy or because he is
actually a fan of penny and did all this
to get her attention but what actually
ends up going on here is you basically
have her back in school doing her thing
taking some like insanely high levels of
mathematics right so at 14 years old i
guess she's taking calculus which is
weird a 14 year old studying mathematics
in a three-dimensional space but she's
ultimately met by the arrival of this
reality's daredevil and it's kind of
cool here because what she's told is
that with mysterio having been captured
and him basically accessing all these
gasses and things like that that it was
basically biological enhancements and
this is an underground thing now this is
cool because what it tells us is that
there are super powered beings out there
but the concept of being someone with
superpowers seems to be highly regulated
right very tightly controlled and that
makes sense right it makes perfect sense
that that would be the case when you
look at the main marvel universe and you
look at like the x-men or you look at
the avengers or something like that by
and large people with powers are kind of
given free reign so long as they're good
guys the only ones who are reeled in
here are usually just bad guys because
they're people who commit crimes but
it's not because they have powers that
they end up being jailed it's because
they're doing nefarious things and just
happen to be using their powers to
achieve those things and so when you
look at like the avengers for example up
until the events of civil war in the
introduction of the superhuman
registration act it was just whatever
happened happened right i mean heroes
would try to minimize collateral damage
but if there was collateral damage well
that's just the cost of doing business
and that was basically it then so it
makes sense that if you had something
akin to that again we're not really
given the backstory of this universe but
if you had something akin to that that
took place which is to say some previous
point in time when heroes existed or
those with powers existed out there with
no real oversight or regulation in any
form or fashion that it probably led to
chaos and pandemonium and so that led to
basically a total containment and
control of individuals who have powers
and so now when you have basically
biological enhancements or groups out
there that are giving people powers or
the ability to influence the world
around them regardless of what form it
takes yeah that would be tightly
controlled
that would be tightly regulated and so
over the course of their investigations
and the information given to them by
mysterio they ultimately end up locating
and finally finding uh where this base
is supposed to be now one of the cool
little things you get here is a little
information about penny's father again
not really enough to go on here and not
really even enough to really compel us
as the reader to want to learn more you
kind of learn from daredevil because of
the fact that he worked alongside
penny's dad but he even goes as far as
to say that even through the machine you
could feel a kind of sadness like
something was missing from him but
ultimately daredevil says he was kind of
a cool guy right and so once they locate
this base they basically bust in they
start attacking everybody you know and
taking out all these criminals pretty
straightforward right but the whole time
pity kind of asks questions like do you
think you would have liked me right and
ultimately you know the response to
daredevil is yes the big problem that
you have with this kind of uh i guess
conversation between penny and daredevil
is that there really isn't enough to
resonate and to make the character
overly interesting or at least to give
you a compelling desire to know more it
would have been cool if you'd known the
backstory of penny and the backstory of
her dad the fact that ultimately he was
sort of cold and maybe a little bit
indifferent maybe like his role as a
superhero overtook his role as like a
father so he spent more time fighting
crime than he did basically being a
father to his daughter it would have
been interesting if he had a little more
to that but ultimately penny's asking a
whole bunch of questions and we're
expected to be interested in a person
who literally died in one panel and only
appeared on one page so it's kind of
difficult to sort of draw that interest
in her the other part of this is that
while they did take that gang out that
ultimately the biological enhancements
and all that kind of stuff still seems
to kind of be a mystery out there and so
what this basically does is it leads to
this revelation that they've been doing
this for weeks and weeks and weeks but
they're not really any closer to busting
like the group behind all this than they
were when they started and so ultimately
when she's given the offer to you know
come with daredevil you know to have an
escort home or anything like that she
ultimately says no and she ends up
taking the subway along the way she's
met by spider-ham as well as ezekiel
sims now ezekiel sims will actually talk
about in a future video because at the
end of the day the guy just kind of has
a little bit of a mystery here but
spider-ham or spider-pig if you want to
call him that as you guys know from
spider-man into the spider-verse is
literally an anthropomorphic pig who's
also spider-man he's amazing i love him
he's not as cool as captain carrot
captain carrot oh my god i love captain
carrot we need to cover captain carrot
and the zoo crew captain carrot i love
captain carrot captain carrot's a super
bunny
i love captain carrot ultimately she's
basically recruited by this team and
she's brought in as part of the
spider-verse team to face off against
the inheritors which is kind of
interesting because despite not knowing
them at all she ultimately ends up going
along with the whole crew now here's the
biggest issue when it comes to this so
the nature of edge of spider-verse was
to introduce us to other versions of
spider-man from across the multiverse
and i have to believe and in truth
marvel's main intention here was to
possibly launch like new spider-man
related stories stories focusing on
other versions of spider characters from
across the multiverse whether it was an
ongoing series or whether it was simply
just like a one shot that would that
would basically wrap everything up and
that would be it would certainly just be
left for interpretation it could have
even been an ongoing series like what
we've seen with spider-gwen and so this
is one of those instances where you do
pick up with penny later on but in
reality no one really seemed to care she
was cool in the main spider-verse event
but outside of that no one really seemed
to have a lot of interest in her
character and so ultimately it fizzled
out you do see her after the events of
spider-verse later on down the line but
nobody cared it just wasn't really all
that relevant so let me know what you
guys think down in the comments do you
guys think penny's interesting but i
have no idea if opinions have changed
for the character over the course of her
initial introduction but let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section thank you guys for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace